[MUSIC PLAYING]
[WHISTLE]
JONATHAN KOLA: Hello,
Mr. Kubernetes.
ELIAS PINTO: Oh, hi there.
JONATHAN KOLA: I have a new
pod version for you to deploy.
ELIAS PINTO: Oh, um, just
leave it right there.
I need to rebalance this network
traffic between these two pods.
JONATHAN KOLA: Wow,
it looks like you have
your hands full over there.
ELIAS PINTO: Just
trying to do my job.
It would be really nice
to get some help with all
of this network traffic.
JONATHAN KOLA: You know what?
I think I have just the thing.
It's called Istio.
ELIAS PINTO: Can you
please show it to me?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JONATHAN KOLA: Istio helps
you manage and understand
the interactions and
network communication
between microservices
in your environment.
It is completely
open source, can
be deployed in and across
multiple environments,
whether you're working with
virtual machines or containers
with an orchestrator
like Kubernetes,
and consists of a
number of components
that when deployed
in your environment,
transparently layer on top of
your distributed application
to allow you to do things like
monitoring and load balancing
without any code changes.
In this short
walk-through, we'll
see how we can use Istio to
do very fine-grained traffic
routing in a distributed
application deployed
on Kubernetes.
This becomes useful
when deploying updates
to your application with
patterns like Canary
or blue-green deployments.
I have a cluster running on
Google Kubernetes Engine.
And I've already
configured it to ensure
that any pod I deploy into
my cluster uses Istio.
So I'm going to be able
to monitor and control
the traffic to and from these
pods for free without any code
changes.
Currently running
on this cluster,
I have a very simple application
that consists of two services.
The first service
is the UI service.
This service is responsible
for rendering and serving
the user interface upon
request from the outside world.
I have another service
called the color service,
which specifies the color
of particular UI components.
So before the UI service can
render and serve the page,
it has to consult
the color service
to know what colors to use.
Taking a look at
the pods, we should
see that I only have one
pod serving the UI service
and four pods serving
the color service.
Now suppose you want to roll
out a newer version of the color
service, but you don't
want to go all in,
but want to roll it out
gradually in controlled stages.
For example, here I have a
second version of my color
service that I want to deploy.
You could use Kubernetes
deployments for that.
You create another deployment.
You label it
appropriately, so that it's
included in the same
load balanced group
as the v1 service.
Then gradually change the ratio
of v2 pods to v1 pods to route
the desired amount of
traffic to either version.
So let's go ahead and
deploy that v2 service.
And we can verify that it
was deployed successfully.
And here, we can see we have
one v2 pod and four v1 pods.
Now when I go to
my application, I
see my UI is displaying
a blue button.
The color is coming
from a v1 service.
But as I refresh the
button multiple times,
I see a green
button on occasion,
which is coming from
my v2 color service.
And this happens about
roughly 20% of the time.
Now, the limitation
of this approach
is that the only way to control
the percentage of traffic that
goes to either pod is
by directly scaling
each version up or down.
So if you only want 10%
traffic to hit your v2 pod,
you have to have nine
v1 pods and one v2 pod.
Istio allows us to decouple
this and shift traffic
from one version to another
independently of the number
of replicas for either service.
Istio introduces a resource
called a virtual service, which
allows me to do that.
To deploy a virtual
service, I specify
how much traffic I want
to go to each service
and the virtual service resource
will ensure these proportions
are honored irrespective of
how many pods of each service
is actually present.
So taking a look here, I have
a virtual service defined
that is configured to
send 100% of traffic
to my v1 pod and none
to the v2 service.
Now, we can deploy
this configuration
and actually test
that this is the case.
And when I switch
to my application,
I can see that no matter how
many times I refresh, I always
get served the blue button.
That's my v1 service.
Now if I go back to
my configuration,
I can switch this.
I can route 90% of my
traffic to my v1 service
and 10% of the traffic
to the v2 service.
And if I deploy this again,
we should see a predictable
result. Roughly 10% of requests
will get served a green button,
and the rest-- the 90%--
will get served a blue button.
Taking this further, I can
switch the weights to 50/50--
so 50% of traffic
to the v1 service,
50% of traffic to
the v2 service--
and deploy this change.
And if I go back
to the application,
I should see roughly
every other time,
the button is either
blue or green.
And then finally, I can
route 100% of my traffic
to the v2 service and 0% of
traffic to the v1 service.
Apply that change, and if I
go back to my application,
I should always get
served the green button.
And going back to
our deployments
just to verify that the
ratios are still the same,
we should still see only
one v2 pod and four v1 pods.
So using Istio, you really
get a deep level of control
over how your traffic is routed
across your microservices.
Hey, Mr. Kubernetes.
You're looking a little better.
ELIAS PINTO: Thank
you, Jonathan,
so much for showing me Istio.
I now spend my day making
sure my services are up
and I don't have to play
traffic cop anymore.
JONATHAN KOLA: That's right.
Using Istio gives you a lot
of control over the traffic
with a lot more ease.
ELIAS PINTO: Exactly.
Don't forget to like,
comment, and subscribe.
And if you're working
on a cool project
and would like to get
in contact with us,
please click on the
link in the description.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]